you're about to see a video of a man
tell you about his experience of seeing
the very first airplane flight in
history the year was 1903 and the man's
name was Frank Wood at the time the rri
brothers had already been experimenting
with what they called full-sized gliders
but none of the attempts up to that
point were successful in achieving
actual powered air flight being born
sometime in the 1870s Mr wood entered
into the Pennsylvania mil Military
College in the late
1890s not long after however he was
called off to duty to fight in the
Spanish American war where he was
commissioned as a first lieutenant after
the war Mr wood decided to open up a car
garage and through mingling with the car
racing enthusiasts of the time he met a
man named Barney Oldfield who was a
famous car racer back then Mr oldfield's
claimed of Fame was being the very first
driver in history to drive a car 1 mile
in 1 minute thus achieving 60 MPH which
was a big deal back in those days here's
a picture of Mr Oldfield sitting in one
of his race cars in 1902 and you
probably recognize the man standing next
to him that was a very young Mr Henry
Ford who was at the time just tinkering
around with race cars the creation of
the first model te that he would
completely change the world with was
still a few years away so one day in the
late Autumn of 1903 Mr Oldfield and Mr
wood traveled together to a Farm in a
little town called Kittyhawk North
Carolina Apparently one of them had
found out about the experiments that the
Wright brothers had been conducting
there and they both were quite lucky on
that cold December day for they both
witnessed the very first successful test
of the first airplane in history so here
is Mr Frank bwood to share with us his
experience on that fateful day in
1903 the interview took place place
sometime in
1975 well we just saw the back end of it
sticking out of this barn and they said
here's our flying machine oh I said it
was a mowing machine they said no it's
our flying
machine well it was a good darn good big
kite that's what I thought it was we had
a little bit of trouble with the
ignition that was making break nothing
but two pieces of metal striking
together and we got it to go in and wber
said let's try it well he had built a
track he and his brother up this hill
and under this airplane with one wheel
and it fitted in this track we got at
top of the hill and got her started up
and running all
right and we were laid down to flight
stared with his arms and feet Barney
said let's go and we shoved it off he
was yelling all the while let's go let's
go and it
went I could run as fast as it was
running when it left the
ground I knew it would fly I knew it was
light enough and they had power I could
fly a barn had enough
power he was for the Philadelphia Ledger
I think it was he said what are they
going to do with it I said they're going
to show it to the dear public sell it to
the government build a lot of them
someday and we say you're crazy he'll go
[Music]
by